so i want you to think about there's two
different people they both have an ask
they want to ask for a favor they want
to get something done
both good people both have good
intentions one
uses an additional word in the way he
asks for something
he gets it done the other one who
doesn't doesn't get it done
why it's because of the power of words
being used i
learned this as an amateur coming up and
i adjusted and today
i'm going to share with you 10 words you
need to add to your vocabulary that's
going to get
so many more things done and more people
going to want to work with you
[Music]
so before i get into the tent to share
with you i want to remind you that there
are two words more persuasive than
anything else that's not in my 10
that i've had to teach over the years
over and over and over again
to my staff to my customer service to my
sales my sales leaders to
every single body and it's please
and thank you but i'm not talking about
those two today
but they must be part of your repertoire
it's so effective
somebody you ask somebody a question
there's nothing more annoying than you
ask somebody a question
that person takes time out of their time
to respond to you and there's no thank
you at the end it's as if they owe you
something they're not going to do it for
you again
and when you send something that you
want something from somebody
just add place to it very persuasive but
let's get right into it
here's 10 of the ones i used the other
day we were sitting in a meeting
and i taught my guys an hour and a half
course on negotiation my staff that i
have here my team that i have here
and as i was going through it i said
here's a couple words that you need to
add to your repertoire one of them
is request start asking
people when you say may i make a request
i have a request can i make a request
sure
everybody's okay with a request who's
ever said no to a request
have you ever said no to a request i
want to make a request
the other day after the call that we had
the meeting that we had adam
was closing a big life settlement deal
and on the conference call that he had
he says pat i just used the word i said
can i make a request
they said sure he made the request and
here's what i'm asking for they came
back
they closed the deal so add the word
request to your repertoire the next one
is suggestion
very similar to request but you're
making a suggestion
request is something you're asking for
that you want suggestion is
here's my suggestion may i make a
suggestion
may i make a suggestion on what we ought
to consider in this situation
yeah sure here's my suggestion boom boom
boom because
a suggestion is not commitment there's
an out i don't have to say yes to it
i can leave it's a suggestion make sense
there's a big difference between a
demand
and a suggestion demand there is no out
suggestion i have an out right next one
to at your repertoire is
mayhei you're sitting in a meeting
everybody's going everybody's
debating going back and forth and you
just say
folks may i may i say something may i
say something yes
um here's what i want to say boom boom
boom may i
may i may i you may be interviewing
somebody and somebody keeps cutting you
off or whatever happens
may i may i may i please may i
yes thank you may i
may i may i so so far we have three
words request
we have suggestion we have may i here's
the next one
let's process this together let's
process this together
so you're going through something like
oh my gosh i can't believe what happened
right now this person said this that
person said this
they're not holding they're under the
bargain and this negotiation they said
they're gonna do for nine and a half
percent now they want to only do for
seven and a half
what the hell is this all about um john
can we process this together for a
moment yes okay
so here's what you've asked us to do
xyz is that pretty accurate yes here's
what we are asking for these are our
requests
is that pretty fair yes what what is
unreasonable right now that's holding us
back from getting this thing done can we
process this together
what is it well it's not really this
it's really that it's okay and then you
go
and you're processing it together
because they're willing to work with
somebody that's willing to process it
together so now
request suggestion may i
let's process this together here's the
next one let me get back to you
what is let me get back to you mean you
sit down you have a great thing that
happens suggestion
you know idea a proposal that comes to
your table hey here's what i think we
need to be doing
great can i get back to you sure
let me get back to you give me a day let
me simmer on this
let me get back to you why this isn't a
tactic
the reason why i say let me get back to
you it's about actually go
and do a pro and con and process it will
come now some decisions you can just
make yeah let's some of the ones let me
get back to you
this allows you to make better decisions
can you wait 12 hours to make a better
decision is there anything wrong with
waiting six hours
can you wait the weekend before you say
yes or no great
let me get back to you and you go back
and you think now the other person may
over the weekend send you an email and
say listen
i know you're thinking about it i want
you to know that we're willing to also
do this great no problem
but let me get back to you let me get
back to you let me get back it's a very
very effective
way when you're communicating with folks
out there the next one unpack hey john
you know uh uh i know what you're saying
to me can you
unpack this for me what do you mean if
you can please
unpack your your your request for me
yeah so here's what i'm really meaning
what i mean is that
oh i got it i didn't understand so when
you and when you ask the other person to
unpack
they they they all of a sudden go into
explaining
things where maybe you knew six of the
things that they wanted from you but the
one thing you didn't understand and now
that you understand it
it makes the negotiation or the business
dealing easier just because you asked
the other person
to unpack whatever they had in mind
right so even if you talk to a customer
that you're trying to sell a product to
you know what uh you know one of the one
things that i like about this i don't
know if i fully trust doing business
with you guys because
when i saw what happened last time nine
months ago when i was dealing with bobby
and that organization i had a very
hard time with this you know john i i
totally understand that do you mind uh
unpacking for me what you mean when you
say
you have a hard time trusting because of
what happened nine months ago can you
unpack that for me
sure boom they unpack it for you here's
what i mean by it
he called me at nine o'clock in the
morning and they tell you their story
then you realize if it's on you if it's
on one of your employees
or what they're saying is they just need
somebody to complain to
but once they unpack it you get more
information next one is
choose you know uh john we have two
choices here
we have a choice to not do business
together or we have a choice to
do business together is it fair to say
that we both
would like to do business together yes
perfect we have two choices
so now can we set aside the one option
which is not doing business together
aside because it's no longer an option
yes great so if we want to make this
thing work together
what are some things we need to do to
make this partnership work right
choice choice choice choice you always
got to give choices to people
you know when it comes on to leadership
persuasion sales
negotiation as long as there's choices
more things get done not too many
choices
but enough choices i prefer three i
think the magical number is always
three choices that you have you know
jack we have three choices here that
we're going through and you know i want
to
leave it to you to make a decision what
you want to do here one is to go with
our competitor
which you've told me that the things you
like about our competitor are
dot dot dot and the things you don't
like about the competitors that that's
that true yes
the other one is to do nothing which
means your current technology wouldn't
be as
good as you want it to be especially
going in the direction going right now
to have an exit
whoever's going to buy your company is
probably going to want your technology
to be as up-to-date so
the valuation of a company is probably
not going to be as high as you want is
that a fair assessment yes it is
and then the next one is to see if we do
decide to partner together and you allow
us
to create the crm for you this
technology for you we're able to do
these things here
that you like the current partner you're
with but the things you don't like about
xyz corporation
these are the things that we can promise
that we can deliver on
so is it fair to say that the middle
choice is out
yes we have to do something fair and is
it fair to say that the things that you
like with these guys
we can do here and the things you don't
like that they can do for you
we can do here how much do you value
these things that they can't do that we
can do
and then they tell you it's great so
look at this point of the game
i think the one thing we learned
together mr jones is that we have
we had three options now we have two
options it's either them or us
so what do we need to do to help you
feel more confident about making the
decision to do business with us
then you see how this this is i mean i
mean you just use 15 different phrases
in here
that i'm about to give you a couple of
them right now myself but the point i'm
making to you is
these are words to add to your
repertoire let me continue with the next
one here
the next one is partnership okay
partnership
partnership you know i learned a long
time myself when i was in business
my business was built on a lot of
one-night stands and by the way i've
said this on conference calls many times
i've said this on many negotiations with
200 billion dollar insurance companies
with 5 billion auto technology companies
i've said this with everybody i said
my entire philosophy was based on one
night stands
and it was a bad philosophy i'd go do
business with somebody
boom leave never do anything with them
again
wham bam thank you ma'am you walk away
and nothing ever happens
it's the value in that there's no
partnership there right uh
john i just want you know in my late 20s
i learned the value of partnership
and the reason why we've been able to do
what we've been able to do with the
company in the last 5
10 years is because we have very strong
partnership we have vendors
but we have partnerships once somebody
becomes a partner with us
it is just as important on me to help
this partner win
as it is on them to win we want the
partner to win
because it's a partnership and when the
partner wants to see us
also in we have a beautiful situation
going on here and we can do business
together for many many years to come so
for me
i'm not looking into doing business with
you for one year i'm not looking into
doing business with you for two years
i'm looking into creating a partnership
that can last decades
is that something that you value yes see
the word partnership
when you're having a conversation with
the partnership is something that you
need to add to your repertoire the next
one is discover
you know uh uh let's go through this
discovery uh
phase here john let's discover
what else we have going on that maybe
we're not paying attention to is that
okay with
yeah so when it comes down to this
is this more important too than this
well no this is more important
it depends but this is a discover so
you're going through a discovery phase
right like in
financial services if i'm working on
morgan stanley dean wood or trans
america or financial advisor i'm a
you know at php i'm doing a needs
analysis
and i'm discovering what you have okay
so for example some of the questions a
good advisor asks is
what is your risk tolerance okay what is
your time horizon with this money that
you have here
i notice you have 500 000 in a cd what
kind of return are you getting on this
cd
a quarter of a percent oh really yes
because it's two years okay
you know what is your situation with
this two hundred thousand dollars or
this five hundred thousand dollars what
do you want to do with that money you
trying to buy a business
no are you trying to use it for down
payment on a house no you're trying to
use it for kids college education
no so what's the purpose i just want to
make some decent return
okay if that's the case if i can show
you a way to make five percent on that
or four percent on that with little to
no risk
and you're making more than a quarter of
a percent would that be something you'd
be open to
yes so i'm doing discovery mary what do
you think about this and mary sitting
right here right
i'm having this discovery come by the
way when it comes down to any major
you know per day yes yesterday i'm
having a conversation with one of my
guys radolfo
and his wife they have a million dollars
they're sitting on the bank okay
they have a million dollars they're in
their mid-30s they have a million
dollars this doesn't include all the
other
stuff that they have to have a million
dollars in cash and we went through a
lot of
different conversations together with
them i asked them tell me what major
purchase you're gonna make in the next
12 to 24 months what are you going to be
doing with this house how big of a house
you want to get next what are the things
you need to get
oh you're about to buy this anything
going on with family anything going on
with kids anything going on with this
i'm going through discovery and the more
discovery we have you can make better
suggestions
to the individual you're communicating
with so so so far i've given you what
i've given you request
i've given you a suggestion i've given
you uh
may i i've given you let's process this
together
can you give me which other one's kai so
that's let's process together
let me get back to you what else do we
have unpack
choose partnership partnership discovery
discover what number is that on
the last point so we have one left i got
four of them here i'll pick one of them
maybe maybe i'll give you a couple of
bonuses
uh you know the next one i'll give you
is
let's see which one i want to pick you i
like all of these here man
uh you know we can go with explore okay
explore is similar to discover but
explore is a little bit different right
hey let's explore this together are you
open to it yes okay
so john you know so far from the
conversation that we've had with
your board and your team and your
organization your executive team your
husband your wife
whoever let's explore this you know
is it fair to say that these three
things are very important yes it is fair
to say that
this bothers you a lot yes meaning
you're not willing to compromise this
zero okay and mary i think you would
agree with that that there's no way in
the world bob is going to
compromise not he's not i've been
married to him for 22 years great this
is why this we're going we're exploring
this together
okay let's explore the opportunity
of what if out of your two million
dollars that you had here
what if we took four hundred thousand
dollars of it and you thought about
getting the commercial property and now
here's why you know
you go and what if let's explore the
opportunity now stay with me here for a
moment just hear me out let's explore
this together and then you make your
presentation right so
so remember this i mean i can i can give
you 40 other words that that
that i'm sharing with this with you i'm
giving this to you because
by the way for those of you guys i want
to have this award we're going to give
them the pdf and
a screenshot for you to be able to do
more uh kai let's make a screenshot for
people to be able to put on their phones
like what do you call it a wallpaper to
put on your phones on a pdf and we'll
text it over to you
in a minute but here's what i want you
to be thinking about
you just watch this video you'll learn
you wrote it down
maybe you got the pdf maybe you got the
wallpaper i want you to right away
text a few people and use one of those
words
right away because if you do it right
away it sticks and by the way
if you use it 10 times it eventually
becomes part of your
repertoire and watch what happens with
the relationships around you
watch how many more things you're going
to get done
watch how many more people are going to
want to do business with you
want to partner with you because your
language change we used to have a girl
in our office
years ago okay and everybody would say
i don't know why i'm always doing her
favors it's because she knew what words
to use
words are like butter you use them
people like it they work with you
the same way a man knows how to talk
dirty or talk persuade a woman
is the same way a great leader a great
communicator
knows how to persuade others they're
doing business with and everyone
enjoys doing business together as long
as you use the right word so my
challenge to you is use those words and
attitude repertoire
if you want to get the pdf text words
to 310-340-132 again text the word
words plural words to 310-340-1132 and
if you're not in the states
go to the link below to get the article
uh to download the pdf
and we'll also put the phone uh
wallpaper there as well for you to
download and put it on your phone so
it's in front of your phone every time
you
look at your phone you see that so you
can start using those words and outside
of that there's another video i want you
to watch
it's negative words the power of
negative words
that can have bad effects on the way you
get things done psychologically in every
possible way
if you've not seen this video on the
power of negative words click over here
to watch it
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye